so you have a job you have dental
insurance you own furniture and your car
is less than 20 years old it occurs to
you that you are fortunate and would
like to do something to help others so
maybe you'll donate to a charity but if
you don't have much to give is it even
worth it can one person actually make a
difference then you run out of shampoo
you do that thing where you put water in
the bottle and swish it around to make
it last for like another two days then
finally you go to Walgreens you grab
your shampoos some deodorant cushion
insoles and a refreshing beverage then
the person in front of you buys a
rednose which makes a donation to Red
Nosed a fact giving is highly contagious
just seeing a stranger do it makes you
want to do it too so you buy a nose and
a hungry child gets a meal but that's
just the beginning at work you mentioned
donating while on a muted conference
call some of your co-workers are
inspired to donate to fact people are
even more likely to donate when they see
someone day no doing it it's like
positive peer pressure you go out with
friends and tell them about donating it
inspires three of your friends a
waitress and some guy in the corner to
donate fact the generous actions of one
person can influence hundreds of people
strangers included family friends
co-workers and beyond to people you may
never even know you inspire them and
they inspire others to donate all from
that one donation aren't you glad you
ran out of shampoo